court says north korea's missile program
is being funded through stolen
cryptocurrency north korean cyber
attacks have stolen more than 50 million
dollars worth of cryptos in the past two
years according to investigators such
attacks are an important revenue source
for pyongyang's nuclear and ballistic
missile program the report says
let's get more on this from clifford
coonan my colleague here at dw business
clifford how advanced is north korea in
areas like uh crypto crime cyber crime
cyber crime yeah it's um certainly seems
to be getting more sophisticated it used
to be when they needed to earn foreign
currency they were the north koreans
would make crystal meth or fake hundred
dollar bills but clearly they're moving
with the times and they see an
opportunity here with cryptocurrency and
in recent years we've seen a number of
cyber attacks um
using malware and fishing and things
like that and clearly the sophistication
level has increased now where they're
where they're able to access
cryptocurrency and hundreds of millions
of dollars worth of it yeah i mean the
unsays uh 50 million dollars alone
stolen the last two years how does the
process work
well basically um a lot of it goes
through um an organization called
the surveillance general which is the
the secret service um and they they've
coordinating with a hacking group called
lazarus which has been uh which has been
targeted by by u.s security officials
and they say it's one of the most
sophisticated of the cyber criminals and
then they go for hot wallets which is
where people store their cryptocurrency
in in wallets that are connected to the
internet and then using phishing malware
and various other things they seem to be
able to access the money so it's um it's
showing a great level of sophistication
and clearly this is something that's
probably going to increase over the
coming years
a u.n report saying north korea's
missile program is being funded through
stolen cryptocurrency dws clifford
coonan thank you